these Casas you're Jane you come for you
Oh will he ever know if you're gonna do
a Tarzan movie why not do it with two of
Hollywood's sexiest arses that's exactly
what happened with Alexander Skarsgard
and Margot Robbie it gets totally primal
and they gave us all the simi details I
was excited to work with animals and
model Robbie
I loved the order that you put it in and
I much animal animals Margaret when
Tarzan met Jane it was love at first
sight I think it's difficult with some
like Margo and not a great chemistry
because she said she's the most lovely
warm personality we had so much fun
together I remember when he answered the
door I knew he was tall so I'd set my
eyeline for you know tall people height
and then here it's the door and I was
like hi there and he like swooped down
to give me a hug and I was like my god
he is so tall
it's those inherent animal instincts
that actually made scenes with Margot
Robbie's Jane a little bit dangerous a
chance to kiss Alexander Skarsgard which
you just missed we just did that thing
in the trade our first kiss thing yeah
having sex in a tree as you do as you do
how do you think we rented it well this
is how it went this is what passion
looks like so we root my costume just a
wee little bit that unfettered passion
is what separates this version of Tarzan
from all the rest so it's almost if the
novel and most of the the adaptations
are about taming the Beast this is more
about releasing the beasts
you